okay so we got a
an opponent from turkey another picture
of me although i didn't know this
noticed that in time
so that was not a factor
we got another slab which seems to be
the opening of the day
bishop g4 uh
this is not great for black i think it's
quite well known that bishop f5
is is a weak move
because of exactly this small order and
because of the trick knight queen b7
sorry queen b3 uh knight f6 check white
prince upon
[Music]
and uh pretty pretty healthy
extra ball at that knight of six i think
it's not great
because i get bishop b5 check and i
develop with tempo
which is a good thing most of the time
57 is forced i take it
i castle and um
i'm an extra pun i have an extra pun
what's that the like
um let's just go bishop d2
[Music]
or maybe knight e5 95
bishop d6 queen a4 key seven
not convinced it will go quick queen f4
immediately
my opponent can exchange with queen c6
but
that's okay we'll play in that game upon
up
it's quite alright 97 we go 95.
um ru casey one we just keep developing
just a sec how to give out my card for
some
some food delivery
[Music]
that's that's the way it is
[Music]
women and food eating up all my money
meanwhile speaking of eating i'm trying
to eat some of these pieces here
but it's not that easy
i guess we just have to be patient
return with bishop d2 and
in case of castles we got knight c6
and now i'm threatening the broken on d8
and if the rook moves there's bishop b4
with a nice little skewer
wow obscure speaking of food
um yeah rook
fda but i don't think that helps like it
could have taken
the exchange in d8 but bishop b4 seems
even better and
now my opponent is in a lot of trouble
we got a fork so my opponent has to give
up
um give up even more material
uh i guess we'll go e4
can't take it because of the knights
hanging on
d7 so queen b7 is forced well took the
knight anyway
[Music]
there we go